um den klimawandel noch aufzuhalten muss
der co2 gehalt in der luft kleiner
werden genau dafür soll jetzt das
gigantische projekt portus sorgen fünf
millionen tonnen kohlendioxid könnten
dadurch pro jahr aus der abluft den
abgasen gezogen werden und über riesige
rohre in zwei leere gasfelder unter der
nordsee geleitet werden doch auch wenn
schon seit jahren an der richtigen
technik getüftelt wird gibt es noch
riesige herausforderungen für das
weltweit größte projekt dieser art kann
es dennoch dazu beitragen den
klimawandel noch aufzuhalten und welche
risiken und gefahren bringen solche
unterirdischen co2 lagerstätten klick
zum science fiction hier gibt's täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen das ist wirklich ein
gigantisches projekt der drei großen
europäischen häfen rotterdam gent und
antwerpen das vorhaben mit dem namen
portos soll einen großteil dazu
beitragen ambitionierte ziele im
klimaschutz zu erreichen denn fest steht
mit 60 millionen tonnen co2 sind diese
drei häfen für ein drittel des gesamten
treibhausgas ausstoßes der region
luxemburg niederlande und belgien
verantwortlich wenn das projekt wirklich
umgesetzt wird könnten allerdings fünf
millionen tonnen kohlendioxid pro jahr
aus der luft gezogen werden also aus der
abluft gezogen werden aus den abgasen
und überleitungen in lehre gasfelder
unter der nordsee gepumpt werden die
angedachten co2 speicher aus porösem
sandstein liegen rund 20 kilometer vor
der niederländischen küste und drei
kilometer unter dem meeresboden bis 2026
könnte in einem ersten schritt eine
leitung durch den hafen von rotterdam
gezogen werden über die die ansässigen
unternehmen ihre abgase entsorgen
könnten über eine pipeline könnte das
co2 in die leeren gasspeicher der
nordsee gepumpt und dort gespeichert
werden die abgase werden da zu einer art
chemischen reinigung unterzogen sodass
das co2 eingefangen werden kann es wird
komprimiert und verflüssigt sich dann so
dass es in die sandsteinformationen
gepresst werden kann auch die häfen im
belgischen gent und dann werben sollen
dann in weiteren schritten an diesem
system angeschlossen werden letztendlich
könnte diese europäische pipeline dann
bis zu fünf millionen tonnen co2
pro jahr transportieren die
organisatoren vom porter sind zum einen
der hafenbetrieb rotterdam und zum
anderen zwei staatliche betriebe aus den
niederlanden das gasnetz unternehmen gas
uni und die energiegesellschaft ebm die
idee co2 aus der abluft zu holen ist
nicht neu in texas sorgt eine große co2
fange anlage dafür dass pro jahr 1,4
millionen tonnen co2 aus der abluft
gesaugt werden
dieses projekt ist übrigens an ein
kohlekraftwerk gekoppelt schon vor rund
20 jahren hatte norwegen ein ähnliches
projekt wie portos gestartet um
kohlenstoff in großem umfang zu
speichern es folgten einige größeren
pilotprojekte sogar von der eu gefördert
doch die kosten sind enorm und die
förderung wurde eingestellt doch die
niederlande sind motiviert das projekt
durchzuziehen und somit große klimaziele
zu erreichen im vergleich zum jahr 1990
will der staat seine emissionen bis zum
jahr 2030 um knapp die hälfte reduzieren
dazu der wissenschaftler
max ace in einem interview mit dem
guardian ich finde investitionen in
erneuerbare energien natürlich besser
aber man muss realistisch bleiben
solange die gesellschaft von fossilen
brennstoffen abhängig ist sind solche
lösungen ein wichtiger hebel auch andere
forscherinnen und forscher sehen die
unterirdische speicherung von co2 als
eine möglichkeit die klimaziele von
paris doch noch zu erreichen
dabei vergessen werden darf allerdings
nicht der durchaus bedeutendere weg den
kohlendioxidausstoß ansicht zu
reduzieren und die industrie auf grün
umzustellen zudem gibt es noch einige
herausforderungen für das projekt das
als das größte seiner art weltweit geht
zum einen ist der finanzielle aspekt
noch nicht ganz safe die planer rechnen
mit kosten von rund 500 millionen euro
deswegen werden gelder der europäischen
union sicher erstrebenswert
doch eine zusage der eu kommission fehlt
bislang 6,5 millionen euro allerdings
gibt es für folgestudien zum
forschungsprojekt die entscheidung ob
das projekt wirklich realisiert werden
kann wird voraussichtlich 2020 gefällt
laut dem hafenbetrieb rotterdam zur
folge haben gerade in den vergangenen
wochen mehrere unternehmen interesse
gezeigt sich am co2 transport und
speicher projekt zu beteiligen denn noch
ist aus höchst umstritten denn
umweltschützer warnen dass die lokalen
ökosysteme in der nähe des bohrlochs
mai plant schäden nehmen könnten
beispielsweise durch die versauerung der
direkten umgebung ein
greenpeace-sprecher lehnt das projekt ab
und bezeichnet diese technik in einem
interview mit shz.de als eine art der
abfallentsorgung das große problem die
vorhergesehenen böden in der nordsee
sind schon mit einigen tausend bohrungen
durchlöchert worden da hier in der
vergangenheit öl und gas gefördert wurde
dazu klaus wallmann vom
helmholtz-zentrum für ozeanforschung wir
kommen daher vorläufig zu dem schluss
dass es möglich ist co2 sicher
informationen unter dem meeresboden zu
speichern wenn sich der speicher ordnet
ein gebiet mit wenigen undichten
bohrlöchern befindet die strömung in der
nordsee könnte austretendes co2 aber
schnell und großflächig verteilen und so
umweltschäden verhindern scheint is for
future zu den protesten für mehr
klimaschutz bei jung und naiv anklicken
hier anschauen und abonnieren auf jeden
fall super kanal bis dann bleibt dran